-President Trump met Russian
President Vladimir Putin
in Finland today, and delivered
one of the most surreal
performances by a president
in modern American history.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Even before he got to Finland,
Trump's foreign trip
was one of
the more disastrous ones
in recent memory.
He was in the U.K.,
where he met Queen Elizabeth,
and he immediately
embarrassed himself
by breaking royal protocol,
and wandering aimlessly
in front of her.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
The Queen
just disappeared behind Trump.
It's like a royal eclipse.
[ Laughter ]
The only thing missing was Trump
staring directly at it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Although, seriously,
you're telling me
this guy only weighs 239 pounds?
[ Laughter ]
He's so wide,
he completely covered a monarch.
[ Laughter ]
He's David Copperfielded
the Queen.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was also asked during his
trip about negotiations
between Britain and the
European Union over Brexit.
In particular,
he was asked about the prospect
of a hard Brexit,
which would involve the U.K.
completely leaving
the E.U. single market,
and it was clear from his answer
that Trump had absolutely no
idea what he was talking about.
In fact, it almost seemed
like he had never even
heard the term
hard Brexit before.
-Because you are
going to the U.K.,
what will be your message
on Brexit?
-Well, Brexit is...
You know, I've been
reading a lot about Brexit
over the last couple of days,
and it seems to be turning
a little bit differently,
where they're getting
at least partially involved
back with the European Union.
-Is it heartbreaking?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, hard Brexit, I see.
I thought you said
it was heartbreaking.
I said that might be going
a little bit too far.
Heartbreak?
Is it heartbreaking?
A lot of things
are heartbreaking.
No, I would say that, you know,
Brexit is Brexit.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Well, he's not wrong.
Brexit is Brexit.
Although I beg reporters
at his next press conference --
someone ask him where
the word "Brexit" comes from.
I bet he has no idea.
"Brexit, I think everyone knows,
is the most
important meal of the day."
[ Laughter ]
"You gotta have your Brexit.
Some mornings,
I have two Brexits."
[ Laughter ]
If Trump weren't
so irredeemably awful,
his stupidity would almost be...
-Heartbreaking.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It would be hard Brexit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But Trump --
Trump's answer managed
to make even less sense
after that.
Watch as he somehow manages to
ramble from the topic of Brexit
to protesters
to how many electoral votes
he won in the 2016 election,
while also making clear
that he doesn't even know
which countries
are a part of the U.K.
-I just want
the people to be happy.
They're great people,
and I do think I have --
Sure, there'll be protests,
'cause there
are always protests,
but I think there were --
There were protests the night
of the election, both ways.
So, you know,
we had a great night.
Uh, protests.
There might be protests.
But I believe
that the people in the U.K. --
Scotland, Ireland --
As you know,
I have property in Ireland.
I have property all over.
I think that those people --
they like me a lot.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Ireland is not part of the U.K.
They famously fought,
like, a ton of wars over it.
Seriously, if you
don't believe me, Donald,
I dare you to go
into any pub in Ireland
and tell them that
they are part of the U.K.
[ Laughter ]
Then -- Then you can use
their free healthcare
to get the pint glass
removed from your rectum.
[ Laughter ]
But if you thought --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you thought
all of that was bad,
it was nothing
compared to Trump's performance
today with Putin.
Before and during the summit,
Trump was obviously very eager
to impress Putin.
At a press conference
in Brussels last week,
for example, Trump said,
"Hopefully someday,
maybe he'll be a friend."
Now compare that
to what Trump had to say
about our
European allies yesterday
during an interview in Scotland.
Trump was asked
who his biggest foe is.
Now, you might expect
that the country
that invades its neighbors,
interferes in our elections,
and uses nerve gas
on foreign soil
might be the first
to come to his mind,
but, of course,
Trump had a different answer.
-Who's your biggest competitor,
your biggest foe,
globally, right now?
-Well, I think we have
a lot of foes.
I think the European Union
is a foe,
what they do to us in trade.
Now, you wouldn't think
of the European Union,
but they're a foe.
Russia's a foe,
in certain respects.
China is a foe economically,
certainly, they're a foe,
but that doesn't mean
they're bad.
-No, that's exactly
what that means.
[ Laughter ]
If you call someone a foe, that
means you think they're bad.
You never heard Batman say
"The joker is my greatest foe,
but other than that,
he's a really good dude."
[ Laughter ]
Also, the real foe
is whoever said,
"This is the best hat
for your interview."
[ Laughter ]
"Are you sure?
Are you sure
it's not too giant and white?"
[ Laughter ]
And once Trump got to Finland,
the charm offensive continued.
Trump made clear
that he was desperate
to get in Putin's good graces
by repeatedly offering
nothing but gushing praise
for Russia's hosting
of the World Cup.
-I also want
to congratulate Russia
and President Putin for having
done such an excellent job
in hosting the World Cup.
It was really
one of the best ever,
and your team
also did very well.
It was a great job.
I'd like to congratulate you
on a really great World Cup.
One of the best ever,
from what everybody tells me.
One of the best ever.
And also for your team itself
doing so well.
I watched quite a bit
in the United States.
We call it soccer.
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone --
Everyone knows we call it soccer
in the United States.
Trump's like a college sophomore
on his first trip abroad.
"You know, in America,
we call the loo a toilet."
[ Laughter ]
But that doesn't
even begin to capture
how surreal this summit was.
However low
your expectations were,
Trump managed to go much lower.
Because just three days
after the Justice Department
issued an indictment of 12
Russian intelligence officials,
offering some of the most
specific evidence yet
of Russian meddling
in the 2016 election,
the President
of the United States
twisted himself in knots
to take Putin's side.
-Our relationship has never
been worse than it is now.
However, that changed
as of about four hours ago.
Our militaries
do get along very well.
I think that the United States
has been foolish.
I think we've all been foolish.
There was no collusion at all.
It came out as a reason why
the Democrats lost an election.
There was no collusion.
I didn't know the president.
What happened
to Hillary Clinton's e-mails?
33,000 e-mails gone, just gone.
I think in Russia,
they wouldn't be gone so easily.
President Putin
was extremely strong
and powerful
in his denial today.
He just said, "It's not Russia."
I will say this -- I don't
see any reason why it would be.
I'm sure we'll be meeting again
in the future, often.
-Can someone get Trump
a glass of water?
'Cause he thirsty.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's only a matter of weeks --
It's only a matter of weeks
before he
"Single White Females" Putin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Do you like my haircut, Vlad?"
So, just to recap,
Trump blamed the U.S.
for Russian aggressions,
attacked the FBI and the
Special Counsel's investigation,
took Putin's side
on election meddling,
attacked Democrats
and Hillary Clinton
with Putin standing next to him,
and said Putin
was strong and powerful.
Can you imagine what
their private meeting was like?
I'm worried he let Putin
annex one of the 50 states.
"Here's an electoral map.
Pick one of the blue ones."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously,
Trump gushes over Putin
like a flustered 12-year-old who
just met Mickey at Disneyland.
[ Laughter ]
and Putin treats him
like a 12-year-old,
as evidenced by the gift
he gave the President.
-President Trump
has just mentioned
that we've successfully
concluded the World Futbol Cup.
Speaking of the futbol,
actually...
Mr. President,
I'll give this ball to you,
and now the ball
is in your court.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right --
Putin got a propaganda victory,
and we got a soccer ball.
Do you really think Trump's
gonna play soccer?
Look at him. The only way Trump
would ever get near
a soccer pitch is if he could
stay in his golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
And it got worse from there,
because Trump went on
to peddle an insane
conspiracy theory
by implying something fishy
was going on with the DNC server
that was hacked by the Russians.
-You have groups
that are wondering
why the FBI
never took the server.
Why haven't
they taken the server?
Where is the server?
I want to know,
where is the server,
and what is the server saying?
But I really do
want to see the server.
I really believe that this will
probably go on for a while,
but I don't think it can go on
without finding out
what happened to the server.
-Oh, my God.
He sounds like your uncle
trying to get the waiter's
attention at a restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
"Where is the server?
I want more bread,
and I don't have any ketchup
for my crumpets!"
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Trump's behavior
would be bizarre
and suspicious on its own,
but we also know,
thanks to Mueller's indictment
of 12 Russian intelligence
operatives on Friday,
the Russian hackers
were not only helping Trump
during the election
but responding directly to him
when he issued
that infamous plea
in the summer of 2016 to hack
Hillary Clinton's e-mails.
You know, this one.
-Russia, if you're listening,
I hope you're able to find the
30,000 e-mails that are missing.
-Remember when everyone was like
"Ha ha! Russia's not
actually listening, right?"
-It now appears
that Russia was listening.
Because on that very same day,
Russian officials
named in the indictment
began hacking into
Clinton's server.
-Not only were they listening,
they were taking orders.
Everyone acted
like it was a joke,
but Trump acted like
he was at a drive-through.
"Uh, yeah, can I get
30,000 missing e-mails,
illegal dirt on my opponent,
and as many Big Macs
as you can fit
in this giant white hat?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, even if we put aside
the mountains of evidence
pointing toward collusion
or Trump's financial ties
to Russian oligarchs
or the possibility that Russia
has compromising
information on him,
there's also the fact
that Trump has a very clear
personal affinity
for authoritarians like Putin.
Yesterday,
his National Security Advisor,
John Bolton,
was asked specifically
about Trump's attacks
on the media
and deflected
by talking about World War II.
-Doesn't that contribute to
exactly the kind of undermining
of the free press
that we see out of Russia?
-No, I don't think that
has anything to do with it.
And let's just be clear --
Franklin Roosevelt
met with Joseph Stalin at a time
when activity in Russia was
a lot worse than it is today.
So, let's try and have some
historical perspective here
and not act like we have the
attention span of fruit flies.
-We have the attention span
of fruit flies?
The dude you work for thinks
Ireland is part of the U.K.
And even a fruit fly
can remember
to let the Queen go first.
[ Laughter ]
And on top of everything else,
today a Russian woman
who tried to broker
a pair of secret meetings
between Trump and Putin
was charged and accused
of working with Americans
to carry out
a secret Russian effort
to influence American politics.
So while that was happening,
Trump was doing
everything he could to
ingratiate himself with Putin.
He's selling out our democracy,
and there's only
one word for it.
-Heartbreaking.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]